ああ
あああ
やばいちょっと風邪ひいたかもしれません
鼻水が
鼻水が止まりません
はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さんは
身近なもの
どこまで目を
通せてますか
まあ、世の中その視野が
広いとか狭いっていうことが
あるんですけども
やっぱりね
やっぱりこう目先の
ものばっかりではなくてね
その目先の
目標に向かいつつも
広い視野で
いろんなものを見て
自分だけじゃなく
周りの人のことも考えて
動きたいですよね
我々人間
今回はちょっとね
すごい細かいマイナーチェンジに
どこまで
そのまさきが気付けるかどうか
っていうのをちょっとね彼のね
視野の広さ狭さをちょっと
比べてみようと思います。
今回用意するのはこちら
今回はこちら
なんか
エロいね
自転車のサドルというものが
あるんですけども
もう普通にあれだよ
自転車に取り付ける
この椅子の座るところです
もうこういう感じで
普通に
これでこう自転車乗る
椅子の座るとこなんですけども
ああう
もう自転車屋さんに
これ３つ持ってく僕の画
を想像してみてください
ただのアホですよ
というわけで今回ですね
まさきが最近自転車を新しくした
というわけで
まだたぶん
自転車のことを見慣れてないんですよ
自分の自転車のその
造形美
色　色彩
タイヤのサイズ
チューブのおおきさ
タイヤのふくらみ
カゴの目の数
ブレーキの利きやすさ
たぶんそんなに細かく
把握してないと思うんで
今回はちょっと自転車を
軽くマイナーチェンジして
それにまさきが気付くかどうかを
ちょっと今回試してみたいと
思います
まじで際どいとこだと思うよ
ほんとにたぶん気付くか気付かないか
微妙なラインだと思います
気付くか気付かないか
わからないものってそうそうないですから
中々今回はいいところに目を付けた
と思います
きた！　きたきた！
というわけで今回は
のドッキリでございます
気付けたら視野の
広い人間
ちょっと本当にね
気付くか気付かないかの微妙なラインなので
是非ともやってみたかった
ではいこう
はーいじゃーきよつけてね
マサキ　はーい
ひとまず一回デュエルしよ
レイジングテンペスト買った？
買ってない
最初はぐーじゃんけんぽん
ちょこれ終わったらさーレイジングテンペスト買いに言ってほしいんだよね
なんか遊戯王の編集ができてないからさー
その編集　いってるあいだに終わらせるよ
遅すぎまじ
あー
ひとまず遊戯王のやつ完成させる
これをこれに入れ替えます
やべばれた？
おいはじめ
あぶないあぶない！
おいこれなんや
おい
これなんや　おい
あーすいません
どういうつもりやこれ
なんやこのサドル
おい
気付くかなと思って
ふざけんじゃねーぞ
なめとんのかわれ
すいません
おう
なんやねんこら
ふふっ